He was a comic genius who had only one speed
- full throttle.
From the moment he burst into our lives as
an alien on Happy Days, he amazed us with
a range of talent that left us breathless.
Yet, behind the manic shtick of Robin Williams
was a man who was deeply plagued by depression.
He had other demons, such as alcohol and cocaine.
Still he kept us entertained to the very end,
which made it all the more unfathomable to
his legion of fans and admirers when he took
his life, at the age of 63.
In today’s Biographics, we get to the essence
of the real Robin Williams.
* * *
Robin McLaurin Williams came into the world
on July 21st, 1951.
Born at St. Luke's Hospital in Chicago, Illinois
he was the only child of Laurie and Robert
Williams.
The family was wealthy, with Robert being
a senior executive at the Ford Motor Company.
Laurie was a former model and part-time actress.
Much of Robin’s formative years were spent
alone in the huge mansion that was his home.
In order to cope with his loneliness he created
characters and conversations in his head.
He was an overweight child, which led to bullying
at school.
The sixth grade, he later recalled, was the
most difficult year of his life.
Many days he went home crying, after constant
name calling and physical harassment.
Each day was a torment for him, with the only
friends the ones he created in his imagination.
The hardship of these early years brought
on a deep seated state of depression that
Robin was to grapple with for the rest of
his life.
Robin began to use comedy as a defense mechanism.
It started with his mother.
Laurie had a very sharp wit and would often
use humor, laced with sarcasm, to communicate
with her son.
In order to connect with her, Robin had to
make his mother laugh.
It wasn’t good enough to be Robin; he had
to be funny Robin.
By the time he was 16, the family had relocated
to Tiburon, California where Robin attended
Redwood High School.
It was the late sixties, and the straight
laced Robin found himself in the middle of
a counterculture that revolved around drugs
and sex.
He was able to loosen up and, after dabbling
with marijuana, found himself fitting in for
the first time.
It was at Redwood High that Robin stumbled
upon the drama department.
He had already perfected his comedic veneer,
quickly establishing a reputation as the class
clown.
He fell in love with the idea of improv performance,
his comedic personality slowly emerging through
drama classes.
At the same time, Robin got involved in wrestling
and soccer, proving to be an accomplished
athlete.
Yet, by the time he graduated college in 1969,
he was voted by his classmates as the ‘least
likely to succeed.’
Not surprisingly he was also voted ‘funniest
student.’
After graduation, Robin attended Claremont
Men’s College, his sights set on a career
in political science.
Before long, however, he was spending more
time in the college theater than in lecture
rooms.
He won the coveted role of Fagin in the College’s
production of Oliver, turning in a stellar
performance that made it clear that he was
destined for the limelight.
Leaving behind his diplomatic ambitions, Robin
enrolled in a community college theater program.
During classes he would often improvise, leaving
his classmates and teachers in fits of laughter.
After three years of honing his craft, he
was offered the opportunity of a lifetime
- a full scholarship to the Juilliard School
of Performing Arts in New York City.
Williams was one of only two students accepted
into the 1973 advance program at Juilliard.
The other was future superman actor, Christopher
Reeve.
Reeve, who would become a close friend, recalled
his first impressions upon meeting Williams:
He wore tie-dyed shirts with tracksuit bottoms
and talked a mile a minute.
I’d never seen so much energy contained
in one person.
He was like an untied balloon that had been
inflated and immediately released.
I watched in awe as he virtually caromed off
the walls of the class and hallways.
To say that he was ‘on’ would be a major
understatement.
At Juilliard, Robin astounded his teachers
and fellow students alike.
He was able to take on the persona of characters
with ease, trading out one accent or dialect
for another like he was born to do it.
However, Robin was frustrated at Juilliard.
He just didn’t fit in.
After two years, his teachers told him that
there was nothing more that they could teach
him.
One of his instructors considered Robin to
be a genius who was not being properly served
by the school’s conservative and classical
training style.
He left Juilliard in 1976, ready to launch
himself on the world.
His first stop was the stand up circuit on
the West Coast.
Comic
Robin’s first break into the realms of comedy
came at a club in the San Francisco Bay Area.
His first gig was at the Holy City Zoo, where
he also spent time tending bar.
These early sets were frenetic, bordering
on psychotic.
No-one had ever seen anything quite like Robin
Williams.
He played a collection of edgy characters
including Reverend Oral Satisfaction.
His early stand-up was influenced by the likes
of Lenny Bruce, Peter Sellers and Jonathan
Winters.
His manic edge, quick fire ad-lib routines
and off-the -wall physical comedy proved a
hit and he soon established a loyal following.
Robin loved the immediate feedback that came
from stand-up, and it was something that he
would continue to do right through his career.
Despite the apparent ease of his performances,
he actually found stand-up very stressful.
Underneath the cloak of his act, he was an
intensely shy man.
He once said that he started using drugs and
alcohol as a crutch to combat his stage nerves.
In 1977, Williams moved to Los Angeles where
he began performing at the Comedy Club.
It was here that he was discovered by TV producer
George Schlatter who offered him a spot on
a revival of the old 60’s show Laugh In.
The show didn’t survive, but for Williams
it established a foothold into a career in
television.
He became a semi-regular cast member on The
Richard Pryor Show, while also continuing
to perform stand-up.
It was an appearance on The Richard Pryor
Show that brought Williams to the attention
of Gary Marshall, the producer of the hit
sit-com Happy Days.
After five seasons, the scriptwriters were
seriously running out of ideas (though they
hadn’t yet ‘jumped the shark’).
They decided to do an episode taking off the
1960’s sci-fi comedy My Favorite Martian.
The episode was called My Favorite Orkan and
called for the casting of an actor to play
an alien from the land of Ork.
Marshall though that Williams might be the
man for the job.
In what has gone down as possibly the most
brilliant audition in TV history, Robin entered
the room and immediately sat in the chair
on his head.
He proceeded to do his lines, and then broke
into an inspired ad-lib.
Marshal cast him on the spot, later commenting
that Williams was the only alien who turned
up for the part.
The episode of Happy Days was originally shot
as a dream sequence on the part of Richie
Cunningham.
However, the character played by Williams,
Mork from Ork, was such a hit with the TV
watching audience after an initial broadcast,
that the ending was re-filmed so that Mork
was a real character.
Much of Robin’s work on the Happy Days episode
was improvised and augmented with physical
comedy.
He spoke in a high, nasally voice, set off
buy his signature greeting ‘nanoo-nanoo.’
Audiences couldn’t get enough of the zany
alien and demanded more.
This led to the creation of the spin-off series
Mork & Mindy, which ran from 1978 to 1982.
The show catapulted Williams to super stardom
literally overnight.
After just two weeks on the air, it had zoomed
to the top 10 of the Nielsen ratings.
The producers of the show kept the script
loose enough to give Robin plenty of room
to do as he pleased - and the results were
unpredictable, over-the-top and hilarious.
While the critics weren’t overly enthused
with the show, they were falling over themselves
to lavish praise upon its star.
Super Star
Mork & Mindy quickly became a pop culture
phenomenon.
A generation of kids took to wearing Mork’s
trademark rainbow suspenders and greeting
their friends with the words ‘nanoo-nanoo.’
Robin went from relative obscurity to instant
fame in the space of a couple of months.
It was something that he wasn’t ready for.
He began indulging in the excesses that come
with fame - drugs, alcohol and women.
Just as he acted in the fast lane, so to did
he live his live in the very fastest of lanes.
He quickly slipped into the habit of partying
into the early hours, crawling home at 5 in
the morning and then having to be on the set
by 10.
There is no doubt that Robin was blessed with
more physical energy than most.
Inevitably, however, that energy began to
burn out.
He would sometimes fall asleep on the set,
or just sit dormant in ‘off’ mode.
One night, after performing a late night set
at a comedy club, Robin met up with fellow
comic John Belushi.
They ended up at the Chateau Marmont, where
Williams shared some of Belushi’s cocaine
and then left.
The next day, on the set of Mork & Mindy,
co-star Pam Dawber broke the news to Williams
that Belushi had died of a drug overdose.
Robin was devastated.
The news shocked him into making changes in
his lifestyle.
The death of Belushi tarnished the image of
Hollywood’s fast living brat pack.
Robin was called to testify before a grand
jury, an experience which, along with the
shock of Belushi’s death and the birth of
his first child, Zak, allowed him to break
free from the stranglehold of drugs and alcohol.
It was at this time that he discovered cycling,
a form of exercise which he credits for saving
his life.
After four years, Mork & Mindy had lost its
midas touch.
Producers tried whatever they could to resurrect
the initial appeal but nothing seemed to work.
They decided to make Mork less naive, allowing
Williams to work in more of his nightclub
act material.
Interestingly, the Mork character also found
its way into his stand up routines, though
not by Robin’s design.
Audience members at his late night shows would
yell out, ‘Do Mork,’ to which Robin would
frustratingly respond, ‘Mork’s not here.
I’m a different guy!’
By the middle of 1982, the character that
had propelled Williams to superstar status
was beginning to feel like a millstone around
his neck.
So, it came as somewhat of a relief to him
when Mork & Mindy was cancelled after four
seasons.
Family Man
In 1976, Robin met Valerie Velardi while working
as a bartender in San Francisco, shortly after
leaving Juilliard.
She was a dancer, having studied at Juilliard
herself.
They began a relationship and, after two years,
were married on June 4th, 1978.
Valerie endured her husband’s cocaine addiction
and wild partying lifestyle for a number of
years.
It was with the birth of their son, Zachary,
on April 11th, 1983 that he finally managed
to shake off his addiction.
However, he was unable to control his wandering
eye.
He ended up having an affair with a cocktail
waitress by the name of Michelle Tish Carter.
In 1986, Miss Carter sued Williams for $6.4
million, claiming that he had knowingly infected
her with herpes simplex virus.
He settled out of court, only for his wife
to sue for divorce a few months later.
On April 30th, 1989, less than a year after
the divorce from Valerie being finalized,
Williams married Marcia Grimes, the former
nanny to his son, Zach.
They had actually been carrying on an affair
during the last two years of his previous
marriage.
At the time of the wedding, Marcia was pregnant
with Robin’s child, a daughter who they
named Zelda Rae.
Two years later, they had a second child,
Cody Alan.
The marriage endured for 19 years, with Marcia
finally leaving, unable to handle Robin’s
relapse into addiction.
Williams married for the third and final time
in 2011.
Susan Schneider was a graphic designer at
the time.
He met her while recovering from a heart operation
in 2009.
They were still together at the time of Robin’s
death in 2014.
Movie Star
Robin’s fame on the small screen inevitably
aroused the interest of movie makers.
His first starring role came in 1980’s Popeye.
The movie was a financial and critical flop
and it looked like Williams’ film career
was over before he’d even gotten out of
the gate.
But then, in 1982’s The World According
to Garp, he was able to show more of his dramatic
acting talents.
The film was well received , with critic Roger
Ebert calling Robin’s performance ‘unconventional
and absorbing.’
Following a couple of smaller roles he got
his big screen break in 1987’s Good Morning
Vietnam.
The role of Adrian Cronauer, a real life Armed
Forces DJ stationed in Saigon during the war,
was tailor made for Williams’ manic style.
In fact, nearly everything that he did on
screen was improvised.
The performance was good enough to earn him
an Academy Award nomination for Best Actor.
Over the next decade, Williams appeared in
an impressive number of films, displaying
a huge range and appeal across the generations.
He shone as both a dramatic and a comic actor,
with his first and only Oscar coming for Best
Supporting Actor playing a psychologist in
1997’s Good Will Hunting.
He had previously received two nominations,
for 1988’s Dead Poet’s Society and 1991’s
The Fisher King.
Perhaps Williams’ most versatile role was
one in which he was never actually on screen.
His role as the genie in the 1992 Disney animated
musical Aladdin showcased his amazing vocal
range.
The role had been specifically written for
him, although he improvised much of the dialogue,
just as he had done in Good Morning Vietnam.
Williams played what would prove to be his
most beloved character in 1993’s Mrs Doubtfire,
in which he portrayed a recently divorced
actor who takes on the persona of an elderly
Scottish housemaid to get closer to his children.
He spent four hours every day putting on his
makeup to play the part.
The movie was a great success and a sequel
was in the works at the time of Williams’
death in 2014.
His darkest role came in 2002’s One Hour
Photo.
Williams played a lonely photo technician
who becomes obsessed with a family whose photos
he has developed for years.
He received rave reviews from such esteemed
critics as Leonard Maltin and Roger Ebert.
Robin’s last appearance on the big screen
was in 2014’s Night at the Museum: Secret
of the Tomb, in which he reprised his role
as President Theodore Roosevelt.
In the 2015 animated film Absolutely Anything
he provided the voice of Dennis the Dog.
It closed out a 38 year career that encompassed
74 movies.
Philanthropist
In 1996, together with fellow celebrities
Whoopi Goldberg and Billy Crystal, Robin founded
Comic Relief, USA.
The charity helped the homeless, with $80
million being raised as of last year.
Together with his second wife, he also created
the Windfall Foundation to help donate money
to a variety of causes, including St. Jude
Children’s Research Hospital.
On May 27th, 1995 Robin’s close friend Christopher
Reeve was thrown from a horse and paralysed.
Robin dropped everything and rushed to his
bedside.
He turned up in full costume as a crazed Russian
doctor, giving Reeve the first laugh since
his tragic accident.
Robin would go on to to donate huge sums to
research into spinal cord injury.
When Reeves died in 2004, Robin was devastated.
Williams was also passionate about supporting
the military.
He traveled and performed at so many bases
around the globe that he was known as the
modern day Bob Hope.
During his career, he entertained over a hundred
thousand troops in thirteen countries
Addict
Williams managed to quit alcohol and cocaine
in the early 1980’s.
However, in 2003 he lapsed back into alcohol
abuse while working on the movie The Big White
on location in Alaska.
For the next three years he denied that he
had a problem.
Finally, he was confronted by family and friends,
who convinced him to check himself into a
substance-abuse rehabilitation center in Newberg,
Oregon.
There he admitted that he was an alcoholic.
After sixty days in rehab, rather than returning
to his family, Robin began living with a sober
companion, who was charged with ensuring that
he didn’t relapse.
Shortly after that his second wife, Marcia
left him.
A depressed Robin did what he always did when
life got too tough - he threw himself into
his work, going on tour to do stand up.
But in the middle of the tour it was discovered
that he needed heart surgery.
The operation went well, but it required quiet
rest time to recuperate.
This forced time of inactivity allowed the
demons in his head to have free reign.
William’s addictive personality led to marathon
cycling and video gaming sessions.
Cycling was a healthy obsession for him, but,
for a man who had struggled with depression
his whole life, being alone in a room with
a computer was very dangerous.
He soon began drinking again.
This time he didn’t care who knew.
In May of 2014, William’s new TV show, The
Crazy Ones, was cancelled after just one season.
In July, he was back in rehab.
Around that time he also learned that he had
Parkinson’s Disease.
After his death it was discovered what had
been diagnosed as Parkinson’s was actually
Lewy body dementia.
After his death, Robin’s wife Susan revealed
that Robin had been been having severe and
prolonged episodes of fear and anxiety, insomnia,
constipation, stress and hand tremors for
over a year.
She said that he would constantly tell her,
‘I just want to reboot my brain.’
On August 11th, 2014, Robin Williams committed
suicide by hanging himself with a belt.
He died from asphyxiation.
His wife, Susan, stated that he was killed
by the ‘terrorist inside my husband’s
brain.’
Within hours of the tragic news of his passing,
thousands of fans were posting images of themselves
standing on their desks with the caption,
‘ O’ Captain, my captain,’ in reference
to Robin’s character in ‘Dead Poet’s
Society.’
It was a fitting tribute.